in this video I want to talk a little
bit about the different types of RNA so
up until this point we haven't really
talked too much about RNA we talked
about it always with you know with
respect to its comparison to DNA so what
should we know already about RNA we
should know that RNA is a
single-stranded nucleic acid we should
also know that it contains specific
nucleotide bases right those bases are
adenine uracil cytosine and guanine a
you CG right the use instead of T's
right T's are in DNA user and RNA
absolute a million times and I'm sure
you've probably said it to yourself a
million times anyway the last thing that
we should also remember is that it
differs from DNA and two prime carbon on
the pentose sugar is an OHA --cz it a
ribose instead of a deoxyribose so we
know all that stuff so there are four
types of DNA or soomi RNA four types of
RNA that we're concerned with they are
mrna trna rRNA and snrna now one thing
to be aware of is that there are many
more types of RNA but none that are
particularly relevant to what I'm
talking about
so I'm just going to spare you that if
you're interested by all means Google
that Google is awesome so I made a
little table here with a bunch of
different things to sort of organize our
thoughts about these things okay
so what is what are all these different
things short for well we already know
RNA stands for ribonucleic acid what all
these little letters mean mRNA is
messenger RNA tRNA is transfer RNA rRNA
is ribosomal RNA and snrna is small
nuclear RNA now they're not all very
abundant what the most abundant one is
actually our RNA and I didn't write here
in pink but this is due to the fact they
make up ribosomes
which are structures that actually make
proteins and we'll talk more about the
details about them later so mRNA is
actually the least abundant in cells and
the reason why is because it's due to a
high turnover rate what is a turnover
rate basically as soon as it's made its
it's destroyed not too long after so a
high turnover rate made destroyed may
destroy it very very quickly so now I
don't really talk about the abundancy of
tRNA and small nuclear RNA because they
bun disease really aren't relevant
actually know what's most abundant
what's least a blended the sizes of all
of these T RNAs are the smallest or rnas
are the largest it looks like large est
but it's just say largest now what other
functions this is where we're actually
getting to the important stuff mRNA is
an intermediate between DNA and proteins
and that's very important so DNA is our
you know our genetic makeup right so DNA
needs to be converted into mRNA because
mRNAs was recognized by ribosomes which
make proteins so ribosomes what they do
is they use this mRNA as a template to
make proteins so mRNA is actually very
very important we'll talk a lot more
about it later tRNA what it does is it
binds amino acids specific amino acids
and it brings those amino acids to a
ribosome during a process called
translation which is the actual process
of making proteins it's the thing that
brings the amino acids to the ribosome
that the ribosomes will then incorporate
into a polypeptide chain
rRNA its function well it makes up about
2/3 of ribosomes so a ribosome is
actually 2/3 our RNA ribosomal RNA which
makes sense right the name indicates
that as far the ribosome is what's going
to be important for ribosomes the rest
of the ribosome is actually in case
you're curious the what the other 1/3 is
proteins so ribosomal RNA essentially is
important for translation and a matter
of fact all three of these RNAs are
important for translation mrna is the
thing that's actually being translated
tRNA brings the amino acids that are
being incorporated and our RNA is makes
up the ribosomes that actually make the
proteins so what is small nuclear RNA
important for one this is really the
main thing I wanted to sort of tell you
guys is that it's involved mainly in
splicing and splicing is a
post-transcriptional modification of
mRNA which I'll talk about a second and
min more detail later and it's part of
so the small nuclear RNA is part of this
thing called the spliceosome which
carries out the splicing of the mRNA so
fun facts about mRNA so in eukaryotes
it's actually modified in five ways it
is a spliced and then there's this
addition of a 5 prime cap and the third
thing is that there's a addition of a 3
prime poly a tail which is just a bunch
of adenine nucleotides attached to it
and this is specific to eukaryotes and
we'll talk about why that is why these
modifications are specific only to
eukaryotes and not prokaryotes
tRNA has a it's fun fact is that it has
these portions called stems
and loops the stems are held together by
H bonds and the loops are are not held
together by anything there's little
loops here so basically this is a sort
of a interesting structure these are
intramolecular H bonds these H bonds are
within that one molecule of tRNA one
important thing that we'll talk about
later about tRNA is is that it has a CCA
attached to the three prime end of it
now there's just two cytosine to the net
adenine nucleotide added to the three
prime end of the tRNA and the tRNA is
important because the three the CCA as a
3 prime end is the attempt attachment
site of the amino acid so the way the
tRNA is actually bring the amino acids
to the the ribosome says it's
translating is by first binding the
amino acid at the CCA portion so that's
again that's something a detail that
we'll talk about more later so I've
drawn little depictions of each of these
except for the small nuclear RNA cuz I
really just wanted to talk about that
being important splicing which I
mentioned right here I forgot to mention
this this splicing is actually carried
out by the spliceosome and this small
nuclear rnas and other proteins so mrna
just it's really really basic it's just
you know a string of RNA with a five
prime cap here that I've depicted in
this little orange circle it's really
not that big but that's mad you want to
emphasize this is poly a tail which is
just a bunch of adenine so we'll talk
about all that stuff more later so what
I mentioned stems and loops I was trying
to get at this here so these here these
little circular portions are loops and
notice nothing is holding them together
but these stems you this is all one
strand right this strand is held
together at certain portions those
portions are stems so this is kind of
how a tRNA looks it has a CCA at the
three prime end and that is the attached
site of an amino acid so this would be
an amino acid attached to it okay we'll
talk more about that again later
rrnas this is crazy I don't even know
what I drew here it looks kind of like a
dragon riding a unicorn but what I'm
trying to get at here is that RNAs are
really really complex in their
structures um it's nothing that I can
simply picked simply like I can with
these two so I had a little fun with a
druid dragon riding a unicorn so I hope
that was a pretty helpful video overall
as a sort of introduction to the types
of RNAs and Dragons riding ridet
unicorns one more thing I am a tutor if
you live in Southern California feel
free to contact me via email at booth
University at gmail.com and see the
description below for more details
thank you for watching